hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 3 now the full game has been
released and a lot of Secrets are
already being discovered about the game
but there's one thing in particular that
I want you guys to see before we move on
to the third night and that's these
three images that I'm showing right now
these are secret screens that pop up
when some people rarely start the game
and it's very weird to see this because
this kind of leads into what the phone
guy was saying on his archival footage
that was found by the stabbing of guy
and apparently this guy's name is
spring-trap so that connects because the
phone guy introduced a new concept that
was never heard of before the fact that
these animatronic suits can be worn and
there are hybrid suits i'll get more on
that later
hi I see you in there okay that does
work I can lead them from room to room
with the noises that's what some people
were saying in the comments and
theorizing that I could possibly do so I
think that's what I need to do it I need
to lead him through this place such that
he that didn't work that time oh boy so
anyway what I was trying to get and what
he just said there was that these
animatronic is that the sound of the
ventilation air because I don't think I
heard it last time probably because I
was panicking a little too hard but
anyway I just fixed it you can't tell me
that I didn't fix it because I fix it
it's clearly being fixed right now okay
so anyway what I'm trying to get it is
that the animatronic suits always
already in there go away god I should
have rebooted all on Barbara knock i'm
farber knocks oh I'm trying to say
something here okay so before I die
spring-loaded animatronics if you're in
them and it goes off you die and those
pictures in the beginning that I showed
you were evidence to the point that the
guys name is spring-trap apparently
that's his name and someone is in that
suit he's very dead probably but maybe
not I don't know but someone is in that
suit and the spring-trap isn't just an
animatronic anymore he's like both or
he's just a person that is struggling to
stay alive what the hell was that
is that golden freddy was that normal
Freddy I don't know back to like my
brain is in the past it in the future
right now be and trying to be in the
present because I can't [ __ ] figure
out what it wants for me okay calm down
game Jesus Oh goddamn it eyes
I know ventilation error I know no
balloon boy you're a dick I get it
remind me to punch you in the face ten
times more than usual hey hi what do I
do about you going to stare them down to
death they can't get you whatever your
name is spring-trap bunny balls it
bastard whatever I don't remember
here we go again god damn it hey there
he is so I can lead him over here oh no
not like that I do not I lead him over
there he's gonna move from there and
he's gonna go here yeah there is okay so
I can move them to the other area which
would be the farthest point away from me
if I go here and he's gonna pop up over
there Yes No maybe I see you in the
corner there peeking out behind the cam
ten figure you hide from me in the cam
ten so if I just leave him back and
forth in between two spaces does that
mean he's not ever gonna get me now
you're the same don't try to mess with
me don't try to pull a fast one on me
everyone knows that I lose my audio Erik
of course this is good this means I'm
actually learning about the game
it means I'm smart enough to learn about
game okay how about over here yeah there
you are that's good hey right there
Jesus okay alright that's okay I'm
hallucinating for some goddamn reason
more than usual probably because it's
night three and this is actually that
why is that happening okay never mind
then I guess I'm fine this is fine
I just need to calm down because I think
I have a grasp on the situation I think
I can beat this because I just need to
go back and forth and make sure that he
stays as far away from me as possible so
if I keep him over there than he might
my
oh [ __ ] where is he okay he's over there
god damn and then he moved again which
means he's in chem seven whoa Jesus
Christ oh god Dan the whole crew is
coming back even though why that doesn't
make any sense okay
no Balloon Boy I know you're giving me a
problem cuz it's getting closer
come on khakha my god Maude Maude how do
I even need to check the ventilation
system because I don't know woky where
is he where is he I'm just gonna play an
audio me screaming a novice alone all
scared isn't gonna help anybody and why
didn't the dude Meister call me not that
I'm desperate for his call and attention
or whatever but you know some company
would be nice and just die what is that
about there well that's it Freddy is
that a poster is that a thing anywhere I
don't care so I know I'm okay fine what
am i okay now
oh that's the vents well that's the
vents oh that's the vents oh that
sounded like a whole bunch of vents
I need a buck you know I don't know
where he is
where did he go goddamnit let's go over
here come on play with foxy for a little
bit
was he peeking out from mind the door I
didn't see him god damn I lost track of
him I couldn't get him back man you
really gotta watch the cameras because
if he doesn't come around like I don't
know why but springtrap's jumps here is
like the least intense all that who is
with Freddy just walking to my logo
oh I'm Freddy okay come here any minute
now okay thank you
where's I got to find him I have to find
him because if I don't find him then
this is all pointless hell is he
to stop that
Jesus he was just gone they literally
just saw him
that was new okay damn it I lost track
of him right when I had him right then
and there I saw him he's gonna follow me
over so hard okay where is he huh no I
didn't I didn't see nothing blue boy did
you go away
I switched okay the trick to beat
Balloon Boy is to switch oh that's not a
good sound I know good sounds that
that's that that's the Evelina that's
not good so if I can just lead them away
lead them away lead them away lead them
away later boy you might be able to go
away forever and ever and ever in the
ditch and go to hell and then never have
to see me again
oh damn it there he is hey buddy how's
gone you wanna you want to get a noise
like over there like over there there's
a bunch of noises like noisy noises I
heard the noisiest noise I ever heard
over in room 10 room is that a room at
room 10 you might want to check out room
10 because room 10 whoa boy let me tell
you all the stuff that's in room 10 room
oh it's got amazing this cake there's
bunny rabbits flown out everywhere you
love it I seem to be in a bit of trouble
don't worry about the flashing light
let's just have a conversation you and
me because I really want to get to know
you as a person cuz I know there's a
person in there and I know that you're a
person at heart and you're really kind
and cherished and you know I feel a
deeper connection now that we're looking
at each other in the eyes excuse me for
a second
I can't have it [ __ ] I'm not okay with
this it's very stressful does you okay
very stressful ah there you are I see
you I see you okay so get back to it get
back get back at least the other
[ __ ] aren't bothering me that much
thought I did anyway god ah hi okay I
don't have time for you I don't have
time for you where the [ __ ] did he go I
see you on the corner by dickbag I don't
much care for it I don't know god damn
it
don't don't even don't I feel like I
missed him I feel like I missed him and
he's gonna be pure pure pure pinup he's
gonna be pure p'n he's gonna puke so
good oh there he's okay he's there go
back come on back back back back demon
back back to the pit hell okay where is
he he's got to be in here he was in here
I saw him whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa did I
see a thing
I don't know I'm going crazy anywhere
got the eye I need to risk it like he's
somewhere in there I just don't see him
Oh No
you can't doubleday me like that now is
chica the internet wouldn't approve okay
it's fine fix that he's probably going
back to five now on his way to four
unless he takes some Dutch for you
okay so yeah he's back in five so I
could get him back to six should be fine
4 a.m. plenty of time
Freddy come on in we'll have a nice tea
party and then you can go [ __ ] yourself
Oh God don't mess with me okay seven
connects to the these cameras till seal
does that seal that better seal them
good oh that better I've sealed them
appropriately because if he's not he's
gonna be right outside my door very
quickly oh god don't kill me I got Nadia
where please tell me that signal went
through bad poetry fine I am come on if
he's just in my doorway I'm just gonna
have a nice little tea party with him oh
you know what I just met your friends
like chica and blue boy came back
together we had a big gang bang together
we had so much fun in a big orgy pile
with all the spare parts it was great
let me tell you oh let me tell you all
the improvements that chicas made oh you
really classed up her face by smudging
dirt everywhere and then Balloon Boy God
you know he was annoying before now I
graduated to terrifying and you're not
listening to me are you
there's only a little bit of time left
before I start black it out hey you know
I like these conversations that we have
because it gets me and you together and
you know that scientists say the direct
icon I really [ __ ] hope
damn fine fine [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you
god damn and I thought I sealed the
goddamn vent in time I tried to hold the
button down you need to double-click it
die [ __ ] come on come on baby come on
baby
where's Ovid then Ben Ben came fourteen
your I'll seal it off baby I said see
you later [ __ ] off well I sealed it
off I sealed it as quick as I could
god dammit [ __ ] I think the trick is I
just I need not to get him to 10 because
10 is a death trap because if he's at 10
he can come right into my office with no
inhibitions okay I saw him in the
background there I saw absolute right
there
I'm gonna start hallucinating after a
bit of this because I don't think I can
deal
oh I heard that I heard that Oh get
sealed [ __ ] get sealed [ __ ] oh no you
can't go through too bad
ventilation air good I hope you
suffocate audio devices of course little
bloom boy voice box they ripped it right
out of his throat you know it's not
gonna be quite working 100%
Oh God 20 mode is gonna be a [ __ ]
it might be a good idea down the road to
preemptively seal vents so that he can't
get to him because if I know hey how's
it going there cuz if I know that he
can't get in a certain vent then I can
control where he is and now would
eventually lead to me being able to do
what I need to do [ __ ] 5 a.m. 5 a.m.
come on it whatever I want it everyone
else has been very calm hey no no no I
don't see in there I'm always
what's that event was that if that was a
god damn it the ventilation system goes
out in that son of a [ __ ] I was talking
about you oh we had the best time you
remember you remember back when you I
told you to go [ __ ] yourself and you
didn't oh I thought that was a very
clever choice you know you and me we get
along so well these days I really feel
you know staring into your eyes this
long scientists prove that it builds a
connection between two people and you
know all in all the lights may be
blaring but I'd like to think about the
red-hot burning love that I feel in my
heart for you I love you at all
oh god I thought I heard the vent when I
went to fix the ventilation error I
didn't need to do that okay so now I get
the benefit of playing chica I'm
guessing lovely chica okay I'm actually
gonna explore around because I'm gonna
take the time I'm gonna cut out where
I'm just wandering but I'll be right
back if I find something interesting so
you guys got that cupcake see boys chica
one seed where's foxy you know that's
the question why isn't foxy come out to
play oh hey whoa whoa whoa three nine
five two four eight three nine five two
four eight everybody remember that that
might be important three nine five two
four eight what's on the ground there no
no whoa whoa whoa whoa wait what's on
the ground does that like shadow Freddy
or shadow shadow warning three nine five
two I guess I'm just following him to my
doom which I can only assume it's gonna
be just as fun-filled as the rest of
them and then we're gonna figure out the
mystery oh look it's all my friends what
happens if I go south well this board it
up to Isis boarded up why are they all
boarded up why are the goddamn doors
boarded up chica No why do I care why do
I care what happens to chica well I was
expected time for the fourth night get
out of my face
okay so that endeavor marked the third
night of five nights at Freddy's 3 it
was a burden but I think I have a deeper
understanding of the game now and I
actually know what I need to do to beat
the game that doesn't mean that it's not
gonna get more and more terrifying as it
goes on because I still don't know what
the hell is going on and all the other
end of products decide to say hi to me
so there's a lot of mysteries to solve
if you don't want spoilers obviously
don't look him up but there's a wiki
there's a tumblr there's whatever
everyone's talking about the theory
behind it
so go check it out if you want to or if
you want to save the surprise to the end
like me I'm just gonna keep playing so
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out the other five nights at
Freddy's stuff that I've done in the
description lower in the annotations
over there thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see
in the next video